for the movement that's dedicated in
their words to free britney
finally hearing her tell her side of the
story was a moment of vindication
i truly believe this conservatorship is
abusive she told the court
i'm not here to be anyone's slave i'm
traumatized
i feel ganged up on and i feel bullied
and i feel left out and alone
and i'm tired of feeling alone i deserve
to have the same rights
having a child or any of those things
[Music]
that was three weeks ago and it set off
a chain of events inside the bubbles
surrounding britney spears
[Music]
her father jamie the conservator blamed
by fans for much of this
called for an investigation into her
allegations he says he's always acted
in her best interests her
court-appointed lawyer throughout the
conservatorship
samuel lingam resigned he'd had no idea
he said
of what she'd been planning to say in
court her mother lynn
one of many voices calling for the
performer to be allowed to choose her
own lawyer
another departure britney's longtime
manager larry rudolph
he said he'd quit because he'd been made
aware she wanted to retire from
performing
it's a judge who'll pick through all of
the fallout in what's become an
increasingly messy
and heated squabble the case has raised
bigger questions about others without
the high profile of britney spears
who are also subject to conservatorships
when hers might actually end is anyone's
guess it may still be months before
britney spears and her fans
get what they want